vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir au lendemain
du coup d'état au burkina faso des
centaines de personnes ont manifesté et
témoigner leur soutien aux militaires
certains ont adressé des messages
hostiles à la france est favorable aux
russes reportage à suivre
nous irons en guinée qui a aussi vécu un
coup d'état le 5 septembre dernier
depuis cette date le pays est exclue de
la zone des changes agua mise en place
par washington une sanction économique
qui se fait sentir surtout dans le
domaine de l'artisanat
principal produit d'exportation du pays
vers les états unis
la coupe d'afrique des nations en deuil
et par une bousculade mortelle aux
abords du stade de lembeye à yaoundé un
drame qui a fait huit morts et des
dizaines de blessés et sur le plan
sportif le sénégal est qualifié pour les
quarts de finale en battant le cap vert
deux buts
on ouvre ce journal par la joie exprimée
par les burkinabè à ouagadougou au
lendemain du coup d'état militaire ils
étaient plusieurs centaines à manifester
pour apporter leur soutien aux
putschistes qui ont renversé leurs
présidents élus et suspendu la
constitution
certains avaient des messages anti
france et pro russie
reportage de notre correspondant kalidou
sy
[Musique]
ouagadougou le jour d'après au lendemain
de la chute du président kaboré l'avenue
proches de la place de la nation était
noire de monde impossible pour les
automobilistes de se frayer un chemin
vuvuzelas pour les uns photos pour les
autres ici tout le monde veut participer
à la fête pour exprimer son soutien aux
militaires putschistes
je venais ccma des poutres soutenu le
putsch voilà nous attendons des
militaires qui le revoir le cas pour les
conditions dans les pays nous voilà nous
voulons qu'ils s'en occupent on veut pas
surprise de convaincre un d'histoire de
six mois un an deux ans trois ans vers
transit soit tu devenu le pays à ça
normal certains espèrent que la gente
militaire mettra rapidement fin à
l'insécurité que connaît le pays depuis
2015 on est fatigués de cette situation
de fatigue et de pleurer on est fatigué
de toujours souffrir parce que nos frais
sont tués nous sommes exaspérés
pancartes anti france
drapeau malien et chant pro russe
[Musique]
après la chute du président kaboré et
face à l'avancée des djihadistes dans le
pays une partie de l'opinion veut
radicalement changer de partenaires
internationaux on a besoin de faire
comme le mali les pays voisins quoi mais
franche m'a dit où nous sommes avec la
manière mais hoewedes en liberté on veut
pas mourir cadeaux on veut que la france
nous dit bye bye et on revient là à les
russes suivent aussi la barre aux
maladies bahreïn en attendant de voir
quels seront les premières mesures
prises par les militaires la vie a
repris son cours normal à ouagadougou au
lendemain du septième coup d'état qu'a
connu le burkina faso depuis 1960 ces
messages anti france et pro-russie
interpelle mais ne surprennent pas car
pour certains la russie serait une
alternative face à la menace sécuritaire
qui gangrène le pays écoutez l'analyse
du chercheur de l'ifri thierry vircoulon
interrogé plus tôt par claire bonnichon
sur notre antenne pourquoi il ya des
drapeaux russe va tout simplement parce
que au burkina faso comme au mali
l'opinion publique est très travaillée
par justement là la tentation de
l'alternative russe à la france
l'engagement militaire français n'a pas
du tout permis de réduire la crise
sécuritaire et cette crise c'est à
augmenter au fil des années et donc la
population cherche une alternative
sécuritaire et comme au mali cette
alternative ça peut être ça peut être la
russie et comme les militaires au
burkina faso comme les militaires au
mali sont aussi travaillée par cette
opinion publique et 7 cette tentation
russe il ne serait pas non plus
impossible que dans les mois qui
viennent on est des annonces similaires
venant ouagadougou de contrats ou
d'accords avec la société wagner il
s'est simplement un grand jeu
géopolitique comme un peu au temps de la
guerre froide qui consiste à marquer des
points et à se créer une clientèle
internationale lautsi au sahel
marche dans les plates-bandes
l'armée française c'est le cas pour le
mali et on va voir si ça vanne ça ne va
pas se produire aussi pour le burkina
faso au mali voisin la france est aussi
sur la sellette
elle a engagé un vrai bras de fer avec
la junte au pouvoir qui réclame qui
réclament le départ des soldats danois
tout juste arrivés dans le pays ils sont
une centaine déployés pour participer à
takouba la tasse force initiée par la
france et qui accompagnent les soldats
maliens dans le combat face aux
jihadistes écoutez la réaction de la
ministre française de la défense
lensoise
je voudrais ici affirmer notre
solidarité avec nos partenaires danois
dont le déploiement se fait sur une base
juridique légale contrairement à ce
qu'affirme aujourd'hui la junte malienne
et en afrique comme en europe la russie
par ses actions et ses discours
privilégie une stratégie d'intimidation
elle choisi la confrontation masqué qui
est un facteur de déstabilisation alors
faire face aux menaces hybride qui se
déploie sous le seuil du conflit ouvert
c'est une de nos priorités de la
présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne à travers la boussole
stratégie on passe à la guinée à présent
vous vous parlez de l'agoa c'est un
accord qui garantit l'accès au marché
américain pour des milliers de produits
africains or depuis le coup d'état du 5
septembre dernier le pays en est exclu
conséquence les artisans souffre car
l'artisanat est un des principaux
produits d'exportation de la guinée vers
les états unis à conakry le reportage de
sakho et maliki
dans son petit atelier de fortune en
banlieue de conakry yahia bas fabrique
depuis 20 ans et sculpture sur bois ces
dernières semaines ses clients réguliers
ont disparu l'artisan est complètement
découragé on voit pas beaucoup parce que
on va poursuivre ses ya pas d hier
la doit s'ouvrir yahia vend l'essentiel
de son artisanat à des grossistes qui
exportent à leur tour vers l'étranger en
particulier vers les états unis depuis
la suspension de l'agoa cet accord qui
facilite les échanges entre l'afrique et
la puissance américaine c'est toute la
filière qui est touché
ce négociant exporter ses pièces en
bénéficiant des frais de douane réduit
prévu par le programme américain
aujourd'hui son activité est totalement
à l'arrêt à la roma a fait
en faveur des containers bo3
pour cet économiste la sanction
américaine pourrait être lourde de
conséquences pour le pays
d'autres institutions qui peuvent aussi
emboîter les mêmes pas que lagoy donc
comme l'union européenne par exemple et
aussi pourquoi pas le l'organisation
mondiale du commerce ainsi de suite donc
ces institutions là losc est aussi
s'impliquent ça peut avoir de graves
conséquences pour le pays en 2020 la
guinée a réalisé plus de 2 millions de
dollars d'exportations vers les états
unis selon des données de
l'administration américaine
allez on passe au reste de l'actualité
africaine en bref et en images une
tempête tropicale dénommé ana a fait 46
morts à madagascar au mozambique et au
malawi là-bas la majeure partie du pays
a été privé d'électricité ces derniers
moore la tempête s'est formée sur la
grande île de madagascar et a déclenché
des fortes pluies des inondations et
glissements de terrain dans la capitale
antananarivo
c'est le pays qui paye le plus lourd
tribut pour l'heure avec 39 morts et
près de 65 mille sans abri
l'armée sénégalaise a annoncé la mort de
deux soldats dans les affrontements avec
les rebelles casamançais en gambie neuf
autres soldats sont portés disparus et
présumés captifs cette disparition fille
suit est les affrontements lors d'une
opération contre le trafic de bois
rebellion il en est aussi question en
ethiopie les rebelles libyens ont
annoncé reprendre les combats dans la
région voisine de l'as far quelques
semaines après un repli qui avait
suscité des espoirs de paix pour rappel
la région est en guerre avec le pouvoir
central depuis novembre 2020 et entraîné
la mort de plusieurs milliers de
personnes et une profonde crise
humanitaire
on passe à la can en deuil et par une
bousculade mortelle qui a fait huit
morts et des dizaines de blessés
conséquence le prochain match qui devait
se dérouler au stade blin de baies de
yaoundé et déplacés dans le stade amadou
ahidjo flaumont rodo
il est revenu sur les lieux du drame à
la recherche de ses lunettes et de sa
carte d'identité perdu dans la
bousculade
louis ngomo a tout vu il était là lundi
devant le stade de mb juste avant le
coup d'envoi de cameroon comores le
contrôle des billets dupas sanitaires se
déroule sans accroc avant ce mouvement
de foule meurtrier des dizaines de
personnes sont alors piétiner et avec
tellement de pichon des gens par rapport
au test qui va les voir passer contrôle
et tout et tout
c'est quand je vois les gens on livre
dépasser les forces de sécurité le
personnel médical ne peuvent que
constater les dégâts huit morts dont un
enfant et une cinquantaine de c'est ce
mardi la confédération africaine de
football a tenu une réunion de crise
première décision le quart de finale de
dimanche prévu à olembe se jouera dans
un autre stade de yaoundé on cherche
désormais les responsables
si la porte était restée ouverte nous ne
serions pas confrontés à ce drame des
gens n'auraient pas perdu la vie à cet
endroit qui a fermé cette porte ou qui
est responsable de sa fermeture est une
tragédie dont se serait bien passée la
caf déjà sous le feu des critiques
problèmes de pelouse d'arbitrage
protocole coville qui changea en pleine
compétition
l'organisation de cette coupe d'afrique
des nations laisse à désirer une 33e
édition de la can à jamais endeuillé
ces événements ont choqué les supporters
mais aussi les dirigeants tout comme le
tout nouveau patron du football
camerounais samuel eto'o l'écoutent
c'est une belle fête mais qui a été
entachée mais permettez-moi tout d'abord
de à mon nom propre et au nom du comité
exécutif que je préside nos sincères
condoléances à toutes les familles des
ehome prompt rétablissement aux blessés
certains ont payé par
le prix
le plus élevé de leur vie juste
en venant témoigner de leur amour
parle à présent la présence au stade
avec l'hymne national du cameroun
comme nous nous sommes dit les joueurs
et nous même
si on avait besoin d'une motivation en
plus bas nous l'avons pour apporter un
bras
de joie dans les coeurs des familles
sur le plan sportif la compétition
continue et c'est la joie au sénégal
après la victoire des lions de la
teranga 2 0 face aux requins bleus du
cap vert en huitièmes de finale de la
can après un début assez timide dans
cette compétition le sénégal espère
monter et en puissance pour la suite de
la coupe d'afrique des nations notre
correspondant elimane dao a suivi le
match dans une fan zone à dakar
la ferveur covas de plus en plus à
monter ou céréales au fur et à mesure de
l'avancée de cette coupe d'afrique des
nations la le match entre le sénégal et
le caviar a été suivi de très près dans
plusieurs fans zone au sénégal
particulièrement dans cette fan zone qui
se trouve dans le quartier de yopougon à
dakar le sénégal a aura quand même eu du
mal à trouver l'ouverture face aux
requins blog du kab'in il aura fallu des
faits de jeu des expressions du côté du
calvaire pourrait mettre au sénégal est
d'ouvrir le score par sa dure année
avant que bamba niang ne marque le
deuxième but 1 des lions une victoire
très apprécié par les supporteurs
amicaux en finale
[Applaudissements]
et il était temps que le sénégal se
réveille jambes montre que la la la la
il est chaud aujourd'hui on a vu une
équipe assez offensive
donc il ya bien paix dont kohler
félicite et on leur encourage de
maintenir ce cap l'objectif du sénégal
dans cette coupe d'afrique des nations
et la victoire finale le sénégal n'a
jamais remporté la coupe d'afrique des
nations il faudra pour cela trois
matches trois victoires à pour y
parvenir
le sénégal va affronter en quart de
finale le vainqueur du match entre le
mali et la guinée équatoriale
et dans l'autre match c'est le maroc qui
s'est imposé face au malawi 2 1 et il
rejoint ainsi les autres équipes en
quarts de finale c'est ainsi que nous
refermons ce journal l'afrique merci à
tous ceux qui nous ont suivis et en
particulier de yaoundé à ouagadougou en
passant par giga sont restés avec nous
car l'actualité continue sur france
inter
[Musique]